when President Putin ordered the
invasion of Ukraine he provoked Global
outrage but some countries have refused
to condemn the offensive and a few have
even supported it
the result of the vote is
is
March 2022 world leaders voted on a U.N
resolution to demand the end of the war
in Ukraine 141 countries voted in favor
but five voted against the move and 35
abstained
the five countries who voted against the
motion essentially supporting Russia
were Belarus Syria North Korea Eritrea
and Russia itself
Belarus is a major Ally of Putin's in
the region with President Alexander
lukashenko backing him from the start
Russia propped up Syria's Assad regime
in its Civil War and still has forces
there and North Korea and Eritrea are
both ruled by anti-American
dictatorships so were unwilling to
support any pro-western motion Russia's
also historically oppose Western
sanctions in Eritrea
China and Russia say they want to lead a
new world order
but the Ukraine conflict is testing that
relationship China is caught between
supporting an ally and its long-standing
rule that one country should not
interfere in the internal affairs of
another it says Russia's security
concerns are legitimate and refuses to
condemn The Invasion but it also
abstained in that un vote
scrutinizing what happens in Ukraine for
reasons closer to home
[Music]
it wants to seize the island of Taiwan
and sees Ukraine as a test of Western
resolve in a possible precursor to what
might happen in the east Enders
India also abstained in the U.N vote
Russia and India have a close history
prime minister Narendra Modi and Putin
had kept that up
India relies on Russian military
supplies but the war has also put India
in a bind it sees both Russia and the us
as key allies India has tried to stay
neutral about the Ukraine Invasion
calling for sovereignty to be respected
but also for Russia's security concerns
to be addressed but since the U.N vote
there have been signs that India is
becoming more supportive of Ukraine
sending humanitarian Aid and Prime
Minister Modi making a number of calls
to Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski
foreign
abstainers in that un vote 17 came from
Africa many have just wanted to stay
neutral but others have openly supported
Russia countries like the Central
African Republic and Mali have close
ties with Russia with Russian
mercenaries helping their respected
governments fighting surgeons
South Africans refused to condemn The
Invasion with President Cyril ramaphosa
criticizing NATO over the conflict
the son of Ugandan president yoweri
musavani even tweeted that the majority
of mankind that are non-whites support
Russia's stand in Ukraine the legacy of
the Cold War is also playing a role
Russia supported other movements that
overthrew western-backed governments in
countries like Algeria Mozambique and
Zimbabwe and its built infrastructure
and provided Aid in military equipment
that soft power approach could now be
paying off
but Putin invaded Ukraine it was widely
thought he sought to undermine NATO and
the West
but ironically it's done the opposite
uniting Europe and forcing even famously
neutral countries like Switzerland to
take a stand
President Putin may have hoped that this
Invasion would Forge A New World Order
he may have won some support from old
allies but the final outcome of this
conflict could be Russia emerging as a
vassal state of China and the West
appearing stronger than many had
expected